one of the big sort of
story lines that we've been following in
particular over the last six months over
the last year certainly in the kind of
trump era
is the reality that the modern american
right wing and the republican party have
this list of stated values which mean
almost nothing to them
as soon as the values start to conflict
with the real world circumstances and
the specifics and the outcome that they
want they claim to have values which
they immediately abandon as soon as
those values are inconvenient to the
policy that they want or to their
perspective on any kind of particular
issue
i have another example of this for you
today
which is a republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green and this is really
serious the reason that this is the
first story today is that this is really
really serious marjorie taylor greene is
now
suggesting saying that there should be
a sort of grace period or cooling off
period when democrats move to a red
state from a blue state before they
should be allowed to vote
now this goes against all
election law
voting law
enfranchisement of voters in the united
states it goes against everything not
even from a logistical standpoint
it goes again even the idea the values
of how this country works and how voting
works and it is in fact
a sort of california version of the
great replacement theory which comes
from france which we're going to talk
about in a moment so let me go through
this piece by piece
newsweek reporting marjorie taylor green
calls it wise to bar democrats who move
to red states from voting
what
if red states and blue states were to
divorce each other that's the word she's
been using representative marjorie
taylor green called it possible that
people who move from a dem state to a
republican state would be barred from
voting for a temporary quote cooling off
period what is this about well
california newsweek rights has seen an
influx in people moving out of the state
many go into texas and florida where
residents get more bang for their buck
however some including green have
complained that those who are leaving
california bringing their political
beliefs with them and potentially
shifting the political landscape
yesterday she posted on twitter
brainwashed people who moved from
california and new york need a cooling
off period her comment was in response
to a twitter user who supports who wrote
he supports discriminating against
democratic transplants including
restricting their ability vote to vote
for a period of time marjorie taylor
greene
wrote on twitter
all possible so pedro gonzalez wrote i
support actively discriminating against
transplants through legislation they
shouldn't be able to vote for a period
and they should have to pay a tax for
their sins and marjorie taylor green
added to that saying after democrat
voters and big donors ruin a state like
california
you would think it wise to stop them
from doing it to another great state
like florida brainwashed people that
moved from california and new york
really need a cooling off period
this is not legal there is no legal
basis for this
they say
that they are fighting the left's
voter fraud
absentee ballot massive dumps of votes
you guys know all this stuff it's we're
sick of it by now and that they are all
about legal voting
well when you move to a new state
you can legally vote there right away
there is no legal basis there is no
constitutional basis there is no
ideological and i mean by that the idea
of the founders of this country by which
you should be restricted from voting
when you move for some period of time
and this is part of the full-scale war
on our voting institutions that
republicans are waging this is not like
an off-handed joke
when we talk about the coup attempt when
we talk about all of that in the context
of 2020
she believes this she believes this and
there's a really good chance that many
of other many of the other republicans
and trumpists believe it as well we
can't laugh this off they don't want
democracy
they want to
pay lip service to the idea of a
democratic republic
um when in reality what they want is
their sort of authoritarian tyrannical
uh rule
by what is increasingly a shrinking
minority ideologically and that's an
important thing to remember
ideologically these people are
increasingly in the minority this is the
great replacement theory applied to
california
we've talked about the great replacement
theory before
um this is uh this comes from france
this is a white nationalist conspiracy
theory it was disseminated by the french
author renault camus
and it states that with the complicity
or cooperation of replacist elites the
white french population and white
european populations at large this is
from wikipedia are being demographically
and culturally replaced with
non-european peoples and at the time
from the late 19th century when this
originates they were talking about arabs
berbers turks and sub-saharan muslims
through mass migration
we have talked about tucker carlson
paying lip service to a sort of american
version of the great replacement theory
when he talks about
immigrants coming from typically central
and south america
making the country dirtier and poorer as
he says and the idea of democrats
wanting to bring as many of these folks
into the country to get them to vote to
win elections that's the great
replacement theory just applied from
19th century france and europe to the
united states in the 21st century
marjorie taylor green's fear-mongering
is based on the same principle which is
they're going to in this case it's
liberals
uh um and what what were the words that
she used uh
um brainwashed liberals
who have committed sins
coming from california and new york to
florida and texas and presumably you
know maybe her state of georgia as well
it's the same idea it's the idea of this
uh
plague or dirty infection from outside
coming in and replicating and taking
over our states like a parasite
attaching itself to a host it is the
exact same line of thinking 19th century
france tucker with brown people from
mexico marjorie taylor green liberals
from california and new york going to
florida and texas
and uh if we ignore it if we ignore it
this stuff will continue to take hold
because if marjorie taylor green is
saying it it's because a bunch of her
constituents already believe it and we
know that they do
so that's her idea
we are of course horrified to see it but
at the same time
need a strategy to activate against it
not the voting piece there's no legal
basis for what she wants but these ideas
are sadly spreading and not only are
they spreading it's becoming more
acceptable to say it in public which is
a big part of the problem
we are increasingly in a coveted
hellscape in the united states as the
omicron variant or the omnicron as some
refer to it including the president um
is spreading wildly uh it is now
believed that there are over a million
real cases a day real infections a day
in the united states as the uh official
numbers are swirling in the 300 000 to
400 000 range most at-home tests when
people test positive aren't figured into
that people who never get tested because
they just have mild cold symptoms or
can't access a test never figure into
that there's probably a million cases a
day in the u.s already
florida is a leading place that is
experiencing these incredible numbers
and republican governor ron desantis is
completely missing uh article from the
hill
where is ron desantis now florida mayor
slams governor amid new surge
orange county mayor jerry demings that
is the husband of congresswoman val
demings by the way
jerry demings criticized ron desantis's
handling of florida's coveted surge
demings and stated a mask mandate for
county employees
some testing sites have wait times as
long as five hours
um
we have not received any assistance from
the state of florida at our testing
sites where is desantis los santos has
been largely absent our residents all
all florida residents should be outraged
and they should ask the question where
is our state where is our governor where
is ron desantis now desantis has not
held a coveted briefing since december
17th nearly two weeks ago
he appeared alongside the florida
surgeon general to promote
monoclonal antibodies developed by
astrazeneca
a spokesperson for the florida
department of health told the orlando
sentinel wednesday florida's containment
efforts have shifted from an earlier
statewide undertaking to a number of
locally led endeavors basically saying
we're not really involved anymore and we
are really seeing a lot of passing the
buck here i already have been critical
of joe biden after running on i will fix
covid saying there's no federal solution
for covet it's got to be run by the
state in the state of florida the
governor's office is now saying there's
no state solution here it's got to be
run at the municipality level there's a
lot of different things going on and
there is plenty of blame to go around
and also the reality that this is
happening everywhere i'm not looking to
uniquely place blame on individuals for
something that is a global phenomenon
omicron is so contagious
increasingly people saying i don't do
anything
i went to the grocery store 15 minutes
and wore a mask and i ended up with the
disease it is so contagious that to some
degree no one's going to really contain
it but we've got to be able to do
testing we've got all these things that
are going wrong
um and uh jerry demings is saying where
is desantis he's just completely missing
let's take a look at a clip of that
our residence all florida residents
should be outraged
and they should ask the question
now
where is our state
where is our governor
where is ron desantis now
when was the last time
you saw the governor do
a press briefing
regarding
covet 19.
when was the last time florida man held
a press conference on covid now
according to the orlando sentinel it was
on december 17th which is almost two
weeks ago and in those two weeks the
state of florida has seen an increase in
covet cases of more than one thousand
percent in fact the state just reported
a record-breaking number of new cases
today the most since the pandemic began
now of course this comes after florida
man implemented oppressive restrictions
just restrictions on private businesses
back in november preventing them from
being able to require vaccinations and
also prohibiting mass requirements in
schools so the numbers in florida are
truly incredible if you're looking uh on
your screen if rather than just
listening today
this is not a glitch this very thin line
for yesterday
which says
46 nearly 47 000 cases in florida
in a single day
that is correct now of course
of course
putting politics aside
the hope is
that the continued lower hospitalization
rate of omicron
will mean that not nearly
as many cases are going to turn into
deaths
unfortunately if you look at florida's
death numbers
it looks like there are almost literally
no deaths taking place we know that's
not true and that's because of how
florida reports deaths they report them
on a major delay so it always looks like
there's been almost no deaths recently
so
we don't really know in florida to what
degree cases are turning into deaths
because the reporting is number one
delayed and number two
potentially incomplete
but ron desantis continues to just be
missing in action as florida nearly 50
000 florida has dramatically more cases
a day now
than many countries many many countries
around the world florida has a lot of
people as well of course but their rate
is off the charts and that's only
official cases doesn't include most
at-home tests unless you call an
authority health authority and report it
and doesn't include everybody who
doesn't even get tested so the next six
weeks are going to be brutal in terms of
case numbers and six weeks from now we
will either come out of this
with an insane amount of death
hopefully hopefully we will come out of
it without a ton of death due to milder
disease that's still the hope and the
belief as of right now
um and with dramatically reducing case
numbers as we are already seeing in
south africa that those are the
possibilities
let me know on twitter at deepakman
which you expect to see uh it is almost
the end of 2021
saturday january 1. is it saturday is
saturday january 1st it is saturday
january 1 we are kicking off the midterm
year
with a huge one-day membership discount
special i would love for you to
participate you can get notified of this
special
simply by being on my mailing list which
you can sign up for at davidpakman.com
forget that the best way to support the
david pakman show is by becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials you also get access to
our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you
people who listen to the podcast or
watch us on free speech tv or on any of
our uh television affiliates listen on
the radio watch clips on youtube
and you can sign up for our membership
program at joinpacman.com cheap quick
easy you get an extra show every day
just for you as well as a commercial
free audio and video stream of the show
and you can get a discount off of a
membership with the coupon code better21
you can also wait for the january 1
discount uh which is going to be big
very very big
lawyers accountants regulators they're
very concerned about how big this
discount is going to be we're going to
do it i will risk jail time to give you
a discount uh get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com you'll be notified
january 1st of how to avail yourself of
this membership special
the david pakman show subreddit is
approaching 34 000 subscribers which is
it's the most subscribed david pakman
show subreddit in the world in fact um
that's that's true it's a meaningless
statement but it is true
davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts i spotted
this morning you know um many of you
know that i like to joke around about
restaurants and food related things and
whatnot
and the other day i tweeted about
you know 90 jokingly but also 10
seriously why is all the anti-mask stuff
happening at places like applebee's and
burger king and whatever and a bunch of
people got mad and said i'm being bougie
and elitist and all these different
things um but uh it's sort of a real
question and i spotted a post on the
subreddit from user colleague three
who said david this is why applebee's
exists despite
sucking david you're right to be baffled
at the existence let alone popularity of
applebee's because no their food is not
anything special nor is it cheap that's
an important thing applebee's isn't
cheap you're able to see it that way
because like me you are not an alcoholic
that is the key to success for these
crappy chains like applebee's chili's
ruby tuesdays to gift fridays etc
the word grill is a dog whistle for
people who want to get drunk more than
they want to eat but need to keep up
appearances so rather than go to a bar
liquor store where the goal is obvious
they can go somewhere and order food
they'll barely touch to avoid buzz
killing and flood themselves with beer
or margarita or whatever
whatever
i've learned this from a lifetime of
having closeted alcoholic friends and
when i would suggest we go to a
restaurant for its wonderful food if
they didn't serve booze friends would
think of some excuse not in the mood for
whatever and suggest one of these putrid
chains instead
a very interesting fact is that even
god-fearing dry counties can be bought
by these corporate booze troths
via the local chamber of commerce i used
to live in conway arkansas which is dry
wow that that's crazy and as far back as
i knew the only way to get drunk was
drive to the next county for their
liquor stores or be a member of the vfw
club oh there's another thing you don't
have young children grills always have a
kid's menu
so you can kill two birds with one stone
shut the brats faces up with dinosaur
shaped chicken nuggets or whatever drink
yourself stupid and they'd then drive
home um
this is very on point i don't think i
have much of a comment other than i
continue to be completely against the
concept of a kid's menu for in my mind
and if i have kids and i go against this
you can all troll me in my mind kids
menu means
what the adults are eating but a smaller
portion
if i go back on that at some point in
the future you all have the right to
make fun of me another interesting post
from the david pakman show subreddit
from samael mager serious question are
there any prominent left-wing self-help
figures
this is a good topic there may and and
samuel writes there may be a ton and i'm
oblivious but when i scan my media
landscape the types of people that mix
in self-help talk and ideas most
frequently are people like jordan
peterson joe rogan and jocko willink
figures like louis rossman who
ostensibly has a channel themed around
repairs but wades into life lessons he's
learned and he's a libertarian bro these
kinds of figures seem so numerous on the
right enjoy talking about their
experiences and how others can avoid
their pitfalls and help themselves and
again where are the people offering this
life advice who are on the left i've
seen david do it but rarely seems more
of a sense and focus on systems and less
of a focus on the individual
i know that's a basic difference between
left and right frames the most left-wing
person i'm aware of that goes into
experiences and lessons is ironically
destiny
um
yeah so i have a couple a couple
thoughts on this first of all
is deepak chopra left-wing like i think
deepak chopra is a total pseudo-science
charlatan
a thousand percent
but is is he sort of considered
left-wing he's like in the woo-woo left
but
that's just one thought i have but i
think that what may be at play here
is
it's less about so so one aspect is the
concept of self-help
is based around the individual rather
than systems it's how do you act to help
yourself the con if self-help were to be
about changing systems it's less about
self because it's not thing it's not
about what one individual can really do
so by its nature self-help is going to
be based around what can you do for
yourself either in actions or in
reorienting your thinking about things
but there's another aspect i think that
skews the self-help world outside of the
woo-woo
away from the left which is
leftists i believe are less interested
in the idea of here is a person who has
the answers
there's an aspect of when when we look
at i've talked about left-wing cults of
personality a little bit like there has
been a cult of personality to some
degree around bernie
that doesn't mean every bernie supporter
is part of the cult understand there was
certainly a cult of personality around
andrew yang
tulsi although i don't think she's
really on the left there was a very big
cult of personality around her but for
the most part if your idea is this one
person has the answers that's the right
wing idea
the the trump literally said it only i
can fix it and his followers fell for it
people like you know tony robbins who
my understanding is certainly skews
right or uh jordan peterson or all these
others part of it is you have to believe
that one person has the solutions and
the answers and that is an idea in my
experience that appeals more to the
right than the left so i think i think
that that's a part of it as well
one last post i spotted
wants to get the o.g david pakman theme
music back on the show
here's the problem i don't know which is
the og theme music so i will consider
changing the theme music but you've got
to email me with a link to the theme
music you're talking about and i i see
in all seriousness i will consider it
but you've got to let me know which
theme music you're you're referring to
um join the discussion on reddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit
all right the this next clip i admit to
you
110
is disaster porn
mike lindell the ceo of mike pillow
the ceo of mypillow who i sometimes
refer to as mike pillow
he
is back on the steve bannon show on real
america's voice war room you know it's a
very long name
and he has a new
blockbuster lawsuit with evidence to get
donald trump reinstated
um
bannon asks him when is it going to
court
and pillow says it's going to court in
two weeks we're gonna do since it's the
end of the year
we're gonna take a tour through 2021
with pillow
all of the different times that he said
he has all of these blockbuster lawsuits
and things so this is the new one he has
another deadline and it's coming up very
soon it's in any it's like throwing a
gun in a river where you killed someone
you can't throw away the evidence so
that's what they've tried to do but
let's go to commercial break just when's
the f when's this filing going to take
place
uh it should be by within the next two
weeks um we've got it all ready to go
we've just got to go get it filed in dc
with uh with the judge
because in any it's like so okay that's
that's the new one in in just a couple
weeks it's gonna happen now remember all
of the times he said this i don't have
two hours to play all of the instances
but let's go through a couple of these
remember back on may 25th
pillow appeared with steve bannon
and he said he's gathering evidence and
he's got white hat hackers
and any any moment attorneys general
were going to be on board and before you
knew it trump was going to be back but
your air game walk us through the
critical path of the air game critical
well it started you know when i first
got the evidence and that was on january
9th and as i got more and more and did
my own due diligence and had teams of
people gathering this what we have is we
have cyber they're called cyber packets
these are forensic packets that you can
change they're 100
evidence of each flip that happened each
attack by china these are cyber these
are immutable cyber packets and
presumably not packets of mustard and
ketchup
and and what i did then is i wanted to
make sure i went out and got site the
best white hat hackers uh different ones
from different uh parts of the
government that are that are protect our
country they validated everything so now
we have our royal flush to bring to the
supreme court but what we're doing now
we have about i believe it's five
different cyber teams different teams
where we're doing awesome he had
elements of cyber and they were ready to
go that was may 25th
um that of course didn't happen
then
he had the august 13th deadline august
13th deadline he missed that one and he
said well don't worry i have a new
[Music]
people want deadline now we can't wait
to 2024 for things to reverse this
country is going down a road right now
that has to be reversed now yeah it has
to happen now it's trump 2021 100
trump 2021
and it's uh this election when it does
get pulled down you know there are so
many other down tickets affected maybe
the supreme court that they just do a
whole new election which is fine but
remember everybody we have to melt down
the machines and make prism bars out of
them exactly melt the machines down now
he said it would definitely happen in
2021 it is of course december 30th 2021.
we are down to the last uh about 30
you know 30 something hours left in the
year didn't happen then we go to october
22nd where mike pillow said he was
canvassing for voter fraud in 20 states
which is of course weird because he
claimed in may to have all the evidence
why are you now canvassing a year after
the election but that's what he was
doing supposedly tell us about your
efforts
are we making pride in your mind are we
making progress you're not a guy fools
yourself right well only in his mind is
progress being made that's actually an
interesting way to phrase it you built
this company out of nothing to be one of
the most important manufacturing
companies
are you wasting your time or do you
believe you're getting traction as
you're going around because i try to we
try to talk every day and i know you're
all over the country yeah right pres
presenting with attorney general's
representing with the secretary of state
the audience because look the audience
loves you but are you wasting your time
are you getting traction on this
no we're getting traction i've uh i've i
met with five states in three days
that's why i couldn't come on your show
this week it's been i've been very busy
i fly out of one state to another i
haven't been named in the states i've
told the attorney general's this stuff
it's all in confidence till we all sign
this together and guys please bannon and
pillow both attorney generals it's
attorneys general they're attorneys
they're not generals please and put this
out the second or two the tuesday before
thanksgiving before the supreme court so
that was that new deadline tuesday
before thanksgiving tuesday before
thanksgiving and then a little more time
went by and again again um this was just
like f a week later
again bannon says it's gene right before
thanksgiving it's absolute genius of
course it didn't happen what i love
about this they said hey if you just get
trump out orange man bad you get biting
you can stop you can start having
holidays again right without arguing at
the table and at each other's throats
but mike lindell comes in and he's going
to go to wednesday the eve of
thanksgiving on a marathon so you can go
back and have fist fights
the family squabbles lindell you're a
genius
like you could have thought of this
the country's gonna go back at your
holidays are ruined again okay no no no
no no it's different now 30 some percent
of democrats now believe this country
was stole and through the machines this
is gonna be do you guys think bannon
really believes this stuff or is he just
entertaining it for the clicks in any
case mike pillow's guarantee of a 2021
reinstatement of donald trump is down to
its last 30-something hours it's not
going to happen it's not going to happen
but there will be a new deadline i am
sure
if you're listening today and you want
to see some of these clips we'll have
them on our instagram you can find us on
instagram at david pakman show and we
will take a quick break and be back
right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow i was
actually surprised how many of you wrote
to me about this story in the few hours
before we started producing today's show
and i want to talk about it because
what's at issue is something actually
kind of subtle
the headlines are trump accuses the
january 6th committee of seeking
evidence of criminal activity and a lot
of you wrote to me and said
how is how is that an accusation that's
obviously the point that's what the
january 6 panel is supposed to be doing
but what's at at issue here is that it
is not actually the job of congress to
seek information about crimes
if they find
information about crimes
in doing their investigation
they should and can turn it over to the
department of justice but trump's
allegation is that that is actually the
prime motive for what they are doing so
there's an axios article that that sort
of explains this former trump's legal
former president trump's legal team
accused the house committee
investigating the trump riots of seeking
to uncover evidence that would support a
criminal referral against him why it
matters the brief asked the supreme
court to consider committee chair benny
thompson's interview with the washington
post as part of its effort to block the
release of records to the committee
last week trump's lawyers asked them to
block the release of documents and
records from his administration arguing
that their release would undermine
certain presidential privileges
in an interview published the same day
thompson said the select committee was
examining trump's actions on january 6
as it considers
to recommend that the justice department
open a criminal investigation into trump
the select committee so trump is arguing
the select committee is acting as an
inquisitorial tribunal seeking evidence
of criminal activity and that doing so
is quote outside of any of congress's
legislative powers
the washington post has confirmed what
was already apparent
the committee is indeed seeking any
excuse to refer a political rival for
criminal charges and they are ewing
using this investigation to do so we're
expecting a response from the committee
today so again if your reaction is of
course that's what they're doing that's
the point it's actually not the point of
congress the job of congress is not to
seek as a primary objective information
about crimes
what we would imagine i spoke to one
lawyer this morning about it what we
would expect the committee to say is
we are investigating what happened
who caused it how could it have been
prevented how can we make sure that it
doesn't happen again
if in so investigating those questions
we come across evidence of criminality
by donald trump or anybody else in our
opinion because remember they are not
law enforcement if in their opinion
there is evidence of criminality or at
least potential evidence to suggest an
investigation they would go to the
department of justice and say
you might want to take a look at this
and the doj would then make a decision
as to whether to open a formal
investigation or not so there is some
subtlety there and obviously there is
room for interpretation and sort of
squishiness there meanwhile the claim
from trump is
their only purpose their only goal is to
find crimes i may have committed or that
they believe that i committed and that
is not actually the duty of a
congressional committee and
that that is that is accurate that would
actually be true
um
i think
at the end of the day
uh it's going to be very hard to make
the case
you you sort of have to go to intent
and if you want to prevent access or try
to shut down the committee or whatever
else the case may be
you really have to get into the intent
in someone's mind sort of like with
perjury did you unknowingly lie or did
you deliberately lie
and it's going to be very difficult from
what i'm reading to successfully argue
that the sole purpose or the primary
purpose or the true purpose of the
committee is to find evidence of trump's
criminality and i think if you look at
the genesis of the committee in and of
itself it's pretty clear that while it
may be a bonus
it may be a tertiary or subsequent a
priority to know whether donald trump
committed crimes
you're not going to be able to prove
that that's really the point of the
investigation it's also relevant to say
that in an abstract sense
it is not the legislature's function to
investigate crimes
but the legislature has a clear function
in creating law
and to create law you need to understand
what took place and how what took place
relates to the existing law that's
completely legitimate you need to
determine does current law cover what
took place or not this was an issue with
the
remember this whole child porn case in
new york state the details i i don't
remember but there was some technicality
in how the law used to be written where
viewing child porn and possessing it
were two different things based on
browser cash and some technical elements
and after someone was acquitted or
charges were dropped on that
technicality i i think it was the new
york legislature said we've got to
rewrite how we define
possession of child porn
we're talking about something similar
here and
the house committee
can very legitimately from what i'm
reading
say
we have to understand what took place in
relation to the law because we are
charged with writing law and if in so
doing we come across the belief
that laws were broken by trump or anyone
else we refer it to the department of
justice i think that they're they are
ultimately going to have that argument
prevail um and again strictly speaking
strictly speaking
if you want to defend yourself on
process rather than on substance which
is what donald trump is doing
that is completely legitimate in our
legal system it is completely legitimate
to get yourself acquitted uh because the
people investigating you
did not use the right processes it's
completely legitimate
colloquially speaking donald trump's
continued behavior is not the behavior
of an innocent man
i want to close out this story that
we've been following this week of alex
jones turning on donald trump
with one final clip which is now just a
straight up threat from alex jones to
donald trump i'm not going to spend a
ton of time on the backstory but as a
reminder monday i played a clip for you
from christmas
where alex jones did an emergency
christmas show
in which he said
something
he essentially turned on trump he said
something's happened with trump
uh trump is now pro-vaccine trump has
always been mildly pro-vaccine but
recently trump said both to bill
o'reilly and candace owens the vaccines
are good
people who are vaccinated are mostly not
dying the vaccines are good
alex jones went nuts on christmas and
turned on trump yesterday we looked at
more clips of alex jones really losing
his mind and just obsessed with donald
trump over and over and over again
talking about trump trump trump and
vaccination
now is when it's starting to get really
interesting yesterday
alex jones straight up started
threatening
to spill dirt that he claims to have on
donald trump take a look at this
criminal we know bill gates is a
psychotic eugenicist piece of garbage we
know who they are
but we're not gonna sit here
and put up with josh hawley or ted cruz
or any of these people
but rand paul's chief amongst them
yeah we all wish trump would do the
right thing but listen i got the inside
baseball on trump he doesn't know what's
going on and i'm not even defending
trump i'm just saying we need to move on
in fact
maybe you know what to get trump's
attention
because i don't even get this from roger
stone i get this from people directly in
trump's camp he doesn't get it from
stone remember that maybe i should just
dish all the dirt off you know what
you know what i'm gonna dish it all on
trump next hour
i'm gonna go ahead and do that and it's
not to hurt trump
so people can know how pathetic he is
when you think he's playing 40 chess
going to save you and he's not he's not
a bad guy
but he doesn't know
what he's doing and he's surrounded by
bad advisors and
he's got that multi-billion dollar
social media network based on mastodon
that they said is an original program it
doesn't even work and there's all these
sec criminal investigations of it right
now and it's all falling apart i wish
trump could go build a real network i
want trump to have success i'm not
against trump
but just like during the campaign a year
and a half ago i told you trump's in
trouble he's going to lose they're going
to steal it here's how they're going to
do it okay
so uh ultimately he did not dish any
dirt but this yet
this is delightful and i have to tell
you
i believe alex jones does know some
stuff about trump i do actually he is a
liar
regularly
but his contacts over the last five six
years you go back to 2015 when trump's
campaign started
i would be shocked if jones didn't have
some up until now unknown dirt on trump
whether he will actually spill it we
don't know
but this
uh civil war within the trump community
is absolutely fantastic partially
because democrats seem to be completely
ill-equipped
to actually win anything in 2022
and we have to hope
it's sort of a pathetic position to be
in but to some degree we have to hope
that republicans damage themselves we'll
take a quick break and be right back
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at dpakman
and davidpakmanshow we're on instagram
david.pacman join the reddit community
at davidpakman.com
reddit and you can also find the david
pakman show on facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy all right everybody final story of
the year of the republican civil war and
continuing to see maga figures turn on
the former president donald trump for
completely mild uncontroversial milk
toast support for getting vaccinated
because the vaccines do a good job of
protecting you from serious illness
hospitalization and death from kovid
there's a guy named wayne allen root
wayne allen root he has been a guest on
this program many times and some of my
interviews with him have been sort of
entertaining i don't know how much we
ever learned when i would talk to wayne
allen root but there was definitely
significant entertainment value this guy
has been one of the biggest maga
lunatic sycophants for years
and he is now calling for an
intervention of donald trump because of
again
very
mild
uncontroversial statements of support
for vaccines from donald trump while
still insisting
everybody has their freedom and no
mandates and no mass mandates and all
this stuff
mild support
and wayne allen root has gone completely
bonkers magazine sycophant calls for
staging an intervention over trump's vax
support um let's take a look at the clip
over the country and basically i talked
about at every poll he's just destroying
biden he's winning by a landslide he's
the most one of the most respected men
in the world more than biden or the pope
he's made a huge comeback politically
and financially he just doubled or
tripled his net worth with a social
media company
and i wrote that for a reason alex you
know why because i
felt it was important to establish with
president donald trump what a huge fan
supporter and friend i am so i could
then come back with my next column which
will be next week which is what i call
the intervention he needs an
intervention from a friend wow because
he's the greatest president of my
lifetime i love him i will always love
him
says george washington until he did this
fabulous i love the guy i just got
married last month i'm a newlywed he
said a letter to be read at the wedding
i'm going on my honeymoon to mar-a-lago
in march i've already booked the
honeymoon to mar-a-lago and the suite
right next to president and mrs trump so
i'm a friend i love the guy
and he's been right on everything except
this issue he's so horribly wrong on
this issue and the best way to put it
ironically is he's dead wrong because
people are dying left and right in just
the last few days a 58 year old
hollywood director
super fit super healthy wiry thin the
guy looked fantastic drops dead of a
heart attack this is the word in every
obituary now suddenly died they're all
vaccinated and they suddenly died there
he is so this is extremely dangerous
rhetoric of course and as we know when
hundreds of millions of people get uh an
infection you know at this point what is
the real total number officially there's
285 million coveted cases the real
number is probably at least double that
at least double that
all sorts of different things can happen
but the allegation there's a football
player we talked about monday or tuesday
who died believed to be seizure related
and immediately it's oh it must have
been the vaccine a director dies oh it
must have been the vaccine this is
extraordinarily extraordinarily
dangerous stuff unproven unfounded but
most importantly
they're losing it on trump for something
so minor these are these are the things
that have triggered people like alex
jones and wayne allen root and others
at a bill at an event with trump and
bill o'reilly
i guess now it's two weeks ago
trump said the following thing but look
we did something that was historic
we saved tens of millions of lives
worldwide we together all of us not me
we
we got a vaccine done three vaccines
done and tremendous therapeutics like
regeneron and other things that have
saved a lot of lives
we got a vaccine done in less than nine
months that was supposed to take from
five to 12 years because of that vaccine
because of that vaccine millions and
millions of people i think this would
have been the spanish flu of 1917 where
up to a hundred million people died this
was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it
it's a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives take credit
don't let them take that away from you
okay so the president made do you agree
with that
right
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too
okay so uh don't don't don't don't don't
no none
that's all there's a very tiny group
over so uncontroversial
it's just i i'm vaccinated i'm boosted
it's an accomplishment it's good and the
crowd is booing and people are turning
on trump then
uh with candace owens candace owens
trying to do her anti-vac stuff and
trump's saying well hold on the vaccines
are good the people
mostly dying
are not vaccinated people here's that
one
we see the corruption right it doesn't
seem like anybody ever pays for the
corruption and right now we're seeing
corruption live even in terms of big
pharma which is a huge topic on the
minds of of mothers especially you're
seeing what's happening at these school
board meetings where do you stand on
these vaccine mayonnaise and obviously i
know that you are you are pro-vaccine
obviously you did everything you could
to get this vaccine out i know it was
one of the greatest achievements we did
it in less than nine months to be able
to do that but where but now it's taken
a twist right it's gotten now we went
from this is a good thing and people
should have this option to
military men you're going to have to
resign because you're not getting this
vaccine where do you stand on that well
i stand on forget about the mandates
that people have to have their freedom
but at the same time
the vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind we would have
had a 1917 remember the spanish flu
killed perhaps 100 million people
actually it ended the first world war
because the soldiers were so a lot of
people don't know that the soldiers got
so sick it was a terrible thing there
was no vaccines it would know anything i
came up with a vaccine with three
vaccines all are very very good
came up with three of them in less than
nine months it was supposed to take five
to twelve years
and yeah people have died under cobit
this year by the way under joe biden
than under you and more people took the
vaccine this year so people are
questioning how the vaccine worked but
some people aren't taking the ones the
ones that get very sick and go to the
hospital are the ones that don't take
the vaccine but it's still their choice
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected look the results of the
vaccine are very good and if you do get
it it's a very minor form people aren't
dying when they take the vaccine
of children these are such i mean even
in that clip trump lies even in that
clip trump lies these are such
basic uncontroversial things and it
again shows you the fragility the these
coalitions are just hanging by a thread
and they fall apart so quickly as soon
as something even this minor
is said so
that's it for
the civil war for 2021 i expect this to
play a major role in the midterms and
these coalitions turning on each other
could at the end of the day decide
who controls the house and senate um
after the 2022 midterm elections
a few of you from canada wrote to me
about this and said david did you hear
that joe rogan has cancelled his show in
vancouver canada over the vaccine
requirement yes indeed yes indeed for
people who don't know what's going on uh
joe rogan has called off a sold-out
comedy show in vancouver because of the
vaccine requirement uh vancouver city
news writes popular podcast podcast host
and ufc commentator joe rogan has
confirmed he's canceled his 420 show
meaning april 20th in vancouver due to
vaccine mandates speaking on a christmas
eve episode of his podcast he said quote
i should probably say this because i
haven't yet my 420 show that's sold out
in vancouver i don't think that's
happening i don't think i can even get
into the country i'm not vaccinated i'm
not going to get vaccinated and
subsequently also posting to his
facebook page that that indeed is what's
happening the show is getting canceled
currently people coming into canada from
the us must show proof of vaccination
and a negative test proof of vaccination
is also required to attend events like
the one rogan had planned so not only
would rogan need to be vaccinated to go
to canada
all of the attendees would need to show
proof of vaccination in order to go to
the event itself rogan said he quote
doesn't trust that vancouver won't cut
capacity at arenas however the province
made the move to restrict capacity by 50
at venues with more than a thousand
seats that was announced a week before
rogan made the comments rogers arena
saying per the announcement of the
province of british columbia capacities
will be reduced to 50 percent
with rising coveted cases we keep
working with local health authorities to
support each other
rogan has opposed vaccine mandates and
to some degree vaccinations and
announced to his millions of followers
in september that he had indeed tested
positive you know i have to tell you
um i have been
so critical of so many of the things
that joe rogan said for so long about
the vaccine i think he's been dead wrong
about so many of the things that he said
many of you have written to me and that
you've said david
we appreciate that you are willing to
criticize joe rogan for the things he
says about the vaccine because so many
of your other cohorts
are not willing or not interested in
doing that i think it's important to
call things out when you see them when
they don't make sense but on this
particular decision
i'm glad to see rogan make this decision
what do i mean by that
it would actually be
glaring
hypocrisy
presumably based on lining his pockets
if he said these things on the podcast
for a year or more
and then went and said oh yeah and
um you got to be vaccinated to come to
my show
and now i'm going to get vaccinated only
to be able to do the show and make money
like in other words there's so much
criticism that i've made about joe rogan
it is logical to me and it suggests that
at least it's not a grift what he's
saying he's misinformed
he's been empirically wrong about many
of the things that he said he's brought
on uh
various guests who also say things that
are completely wrong but
he genuinely seems to believe it and is
not abandoning it in order to just do
the show and make the money to some
degree i'm glad to see that rather than
him reversing simply in order to be able
to do the show and make the money now
it's it's reported that the show is
cancelled
but is also rescheduled for like almost
a year from now so whether we call it a
postponement or a cancellation it's not
clear that you're no longer going to
need to be vaccinated uh in a year to
get into canada so that remains to be
seen but to some degree
at least he is sticking by what he
claims to say
and if nothing else it means he really
believes it he's wrong
he's wrong
but at least he seems to really believe
it and not be doing it for the clicks
which i did not suspect i suspected all
along that as wrong as i believe joe
rogan is on this stuff
these really are his beliefs
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p speaking of joe rogan
this is a voicemail that brings up a
really important issue which we've not
talked about too much take a listen
hi david i was just watching uh one of
your clips about joe rogan talking about
the monoclonal antibodies
i just wonder
why no one is actually talking about the
listed possible side effects
on regeneron's website yes for the
monoclonal antibodies
everybody wants to talk about possible
side effects for a vaccine but nobody
seems to want to talk about the possible
side effects from the monoclonal
antibodies
maybe you should check that out
this is a very important point so we've
talked before there's a group that is
either against
or skeptical of the vaccines
partially on the basis that we have this
great treatment monoclonal antibodies
that's once you get covered so first of
all of course
i prefer
prevention rather than cures as a
general thing so we have to even
separate the antibody treatment and
vaccines on that basis but when you look
at the claims made about the vaccine
that these antibody supporters don't
make about the antibody treatment they
say well the vaccine is experimental the
pfizer vaccine is fully approved by the
fda whereas the monoclonal antibodies
are only approved by emergency use
authorization that's not a good argument
they say well i don't trust big pharma
which is why i'm against the vaccines
the antibody treatment is also made by
big pharma so that's not a good argument
they say well there's a financial
incentive on the vaccination
well it is far less profitable to do a
regimen of three doses of vaccine than
it is to do a regimen of the monoclonal
antibodies we're talking about thousands
of dollars versus under a hundred
total full cost for a full regimen of
vaccines so the financial argument also
doesn't make sense but then you get to
the side effects and the advocates of
the antibodies instead of the vaccine
never talk about the list of possible
side effects and i'm going to tell you
what they are this is for the antibody
treatment fever chills nausea
headache shortness of breath low blood
pressure or high blood pressure rapid
heartbeat or slow heartbeat chest
discomfort and pain weakness confusion
tired wheezing lip swelling face
swelling throat swelling rashes
including hives itching muscle aches
feeling faint dizzy and or sweaty
these reactions may be severe or
life-threatening you may experience new
or worsening symptoms after receiving
the treatment including fever
breathing difficulty and some of the
other things that i mentioned it is
unknown if these symptoms are because of
the treatment or because the progression
of covid
could be affected and exacerbated
exacerbated by the antibody treatment
you also because it is an intravenous
therapy you can have pain bleeding skin
bruising soreness swelling and even
infection where you have that uh iv put
in
these are not all the possible side
effects of the antibody treatment not a
lot of people have been given the
antibody treatment says regeneron
compared to
hundreds of millions of people who have
been given the vaccine it also is
disclaimed and stipulated uh by
regeneron that the covid uh monoclonal
antibody treatment could interfere with
your own body's ability to fight off
future covet infections
and reduce your immune response to
vaccination against coronavirus
that is a mouthful
and all of these people saying well the
vaccine's experimental so are the
antibodies uh
and and no longer is the vaccine
experimental at least not the pfizer
and i don't i don't want those side
effects from the vaccine look at the
list of possible side effects from the
monoclonal antibody treatment i'm not
against the treatment when it is the
appropriate treatment it can be a really
great thing works better than placebo
you've got to be sick though i would
prefer not to get sick in the first
place but a very good voicemail and an
important topic uh and yet another thing
to keep in mind about those advocating
for the monoclonal antibodies instead of
the vaccine when they are two completely
different things the antibodies are a
tool if you get sick
uh but we have other tools to try to
prevent us from getting sick in the
first place on the bonus show today we
will talk about the guillen maxwell
guilty verdicts five out of six
charges we will talk about states
hoarding welfare funds even as the need
for aid grows and we are going to talk
about the imminent increase of the
california minimum wage to 15 dollars
per hour all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com
[Music]
you